[Music]
my team asked me to research vms and see
how they compared other cloud native
approaches
like you know microservices containers
serverless and uh to be honest with you
i am not excited about it at all
so i brought in someone who is uh brian
resident vm expert
hello hello um i'm super happy to be
here because i am really excited about
vms how see this is what i wanted to
bring you here
uh i don't understand how can you be so
excited about vms already
how can you not it is like the best of
both worlds you know you've got a stable
reliable system you can run anything on
and you're in the cloud you know close
to all of the the new features and you
get new automation tooling
so see that's what i'm kind of skeptical
about
uh when i think about modern
systems or anything like that i'm not
sure that a vm can provide me with those
okay well let let's be kind of specific
there what do you mean by a modern
system
uh when i think about a modern system i
think about things like model
modularity i think about scalability and
reliability i want automation i don't
want to have to do everything manually
i even think about portability and being
able to move my workflows wherever they
need to go
so i want things that just kind of work
too i don't want to have to do
everything myself
because that's something i can get with
a vm yeah great because i actually think
we can get most of that
and i i kind of wonder you know
why not so let's let's go one level
deeper and then we'll come back out so
in your mind what is a vm oh
wow you're putting me on a spot right
yep okay
uh a vm is it's it's a computer but it's
it's a virtualization it's a slice of a
computer uh
and so what it lets you do is it lets
you run multiple operating systems
on one machine so it looks like you have
multiple machines running
on one physical machine yep absolutely
and in the cloud kind of not
oh what yeah so here's here's
here's why i say not so the abstractions
are all there right so you've got memory
cpu
disk networking and instead of
from one computer in the cloud that's
coming from all of the computers in a
data center
so you know the cpu is coming from a lot
of machines the networking is from the
whole data
center and so i like to think about it
is instead of a slice of a computer
it's a slice of the data center instead
of a slice of a computer it's a slice of
a data center
that all right that sounds interesting
impressive even uh but also abstract so
do you have some examples of things that
you can get from a cloud vm
that you can't get from a vm on one
machine so my turn to be
specific um yeah
so i think one example is like uh
bin packing so you talk about uh
these vms and they're different shapes
so you have you know one that needs a
lot of cpu another needs a lot of memory
maybe you've got a bunch of them need a
lot of cpu and they don't fit
so well in the same box without kind of
orphaning
some of the the memory or cpu um and if
you're running those
in a whole data center you know or you
can basically just leave it to google to
solve that problem
you can just have whatever shape machine
you want and we'll figure out where to
put it
and basically that lets you customize
your machines
to exactly what you need okay that's
very interesting because that's a hard
problem and so if you can just let
google handle
where your workloads are going to go
that that's that's a good benefit
if that's the only benefit of cloud vms
though i'm not sure i'm sold on them
over
other approaches okay and is there
anything else we got absolutely
there's a ton of stuff we could talk
about in terms of automation
and other things but i think another
really concrete
kind of specific example is disks and
it's kind of my my favorite there
because
you think about physical disk and you
read and write blocks from it right it's
a block device
um in the data center level those blocks
could be on
hundreds or thousands of different
machines and
so all of them are working together to
give you more reliability and
you know make things smoother more
predictable in terms of performance
so what you get out of it is something
that looks a lot like a sand
you can take backups of discs that are
running
even or you can
you know if you run out of space like i
think almost all of us have you can just
make the disc bigger
so things like that that's impressive
especially like you're saying being able
to run and just scale up scale down or
resize
um okay then another very targeted
question it's going to sound like a dig
i don't mean it too uh
google's putting a lot of effort and
resources in the google container's
engine
and so is google even still investing
in vms i mean absolutely
where do you think these containers run
like so every kubernetes cluster
is running on top of a whole bunch of
vms right um
and so every everything you learn about
vms you know applies to those
clusters uh that you're running and also
another example
is you know our managed databases so
cloud sql
so if you're running you know postgres
or mysql on cloud sql
that's running on vms and there's a
bunch of other examples too
i can't get away from vms even if i
tried it sounds like nope
okay the way you're saying that is
making me
think that maybe maybe i need to rethink
my idea that vms are just old dusty
pieces of technology
uh so i want to be clear definitively
are you saying that vms have a place
in a cloud native future absolutely um
so i wanna i wanna kind of like take old
and dusty and and turn that into mature
and reliable right
and then the future part you know so all
these things are built on top of it and
we're building new things
over time so we've got tools for scaling
clusters of machines up and down
that's using kubernetes but you can use
it directly and you know we keep
you know investing and doing more and
more things there so absolutely
part of the future as well so okay is
and then what about if i wanted to
switch to them it like
you know i'm pretty familiar with
kubernetes it's fairly easy to get
started
uh what about with a vm is it going to
take me years to get started on these
yeah i mean it's just a computer so you
know basically
anything that's already running on a
computer somewhere even if you don't
have like the team who built it nearby
you can you can run that on a vm and in
turn you can run it on a cloud vm and
and get a bunch of the cloud benefits as
well
all right i i must admit that
you've swayed me a little bit i'm still
skeptical but what you said made a lot
of sense i
i still have a lot of questions you know
i want to know about keeping costs down
i want to know about
uh how do i update vms i have this idea
in my head that they're really slow to
start
and stop uh staple data i'm curious
about that you know
awesome how much time do you have
[Laughter]
all right you know what uh let's have
this combo another day and maybe just
maybe we can agree
that vms do matter in a cloud native
[Music]
future
you